hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a 2019 american horror science
fiction movie called the silence
a team of cave researchers hammers a
section of a cave in pennsylvania when
they dig deeper into the cave they
discover an expansive and abandoned
chamber in the cave they immediately
inform the surface team about the
discovery of the chamber but suddenly a
swarm of unknown species of bat-like
creature violently kills the researchers
then they fly out of the cave and seek
for the noisiest area
ally is a teenage girl who loses her
hearing in a car accident as she is
walking down the street and watching
something on her tablet a group of boys
mocks her from behind using sign
language
she knows this because she can quickly
adapt to her deafness and can sense
everything around her but she chooses to
ignore their mocks
ally's father hugh and his friend glenn
work as engineers in the middle of their
meeting hugh receives a call from his
wife kelly who informs him of ally being
mocked by some boys at school showing
that ally's parents are worried about
her ala lives in montclair new jersey
with her parents her grandmother lynne
who has terminal lung cancer her younger
brother named jude and a dog pet one day
ally is walking home from school and
suddenly her friend rob covers her eyes
from behind
rob promises her that someday he is
going to buy a car so he can pick up
ally every day they walk home holding
hands
rob seems to like ally when she gets
home she tells her mom why she is late
and then kelly suspects ally and rob are
dating ally sees her dog barking outside
all of a sudden feeling that something
is going wrong
the night after dinner she finds her
grandmother smoking in the backyard
lynn begs her not to tell her mom about
it and she agrees
on the way to her room she sees her
parents arguing about the accident that
allies had three years ago
then she decides to lay in her bed and
watch some news on her tablet as he
enters her room
he worries about her life especially
about robin asks if he's a good guy
at three in the morning her mother wakes
ally up
she goes into the living room and sees
her whole family watching news on the tv
including glenn the news says that there
is an outbreak of unknown creatures in
the cities of pittsburgh and
philadelphia the strange creatures are
referred to as vesp and they are easily
provoked by loud noises the us
government declares a state of emergency
and asks people to stay indoors and
quiet
a loud noise swiftly startles everyone
and they see several warplanes in the
sky
ally suggests them to go to the
countryside which tends to be quieter
they agree with that and glenn also
joins them bringing his gun
they finally set out in two cars
meanwhile ally has a video call with rob
as they drive away from the city they
both promise to stay in touch until the
outbreak ends
after a while they stop at a gas station
to prepare all the necessities ally
takes her dog to pee and it suddenly
starts barking at a man with a shotgun
the man points his gun at her and tries
to hijack hugh's car
just as hugh is about to give him the
key glenn manages to shoot the man in
the leg and they drive away from the gas
station the following day they encounter
a massive traffic jam blocking all the
interstates glenn decides to change
their way leading them off-road out of
nowhere a herd of fleeing deer crosses
glenn's path forcing him to tumble down
the embankment he survives but is
trapped inside the car
hugh initially tries to help him but he
asks you to leave him behind and keep
moving to be safe from the creatures
kelly also tries to call for help but
sadly there's no signal
at the end hugh promises glenn that he
will search for help and return to
rescue him
when the family returns to their car
their dog suddenly barks again
attracting the vesps to attack their car
glenn hears the veps and starts firing
his gun leading them away from the car
and ultimately sacrificing himself
the vets return to their car as the dog
continues to bark so hugh decides to let
the dog out of the car leaving ally
crying in disappointment
after they wait for a while hugh tells
them that he needs to try something and
goes out of the car
unexpectedly lin starts coughing drawing
a vest to the car again hugh then slowly
picks up an iron and throws it away to
distract the vesp he realizes that the
vest cannot see an ally says that they
understand sign language allowing them
to survive without making a sound
unable to use their vehicle due to its
noise hugh asks for lin's lighter and
sneaks to glenn's car
he sets the car on fire as a decoy so
the family can quickly get out of the
car and walk through the woods in search
of shelter for the night
they find a house with a high fence and
a locked gate
they try to open the door but
accidentally make a sound from the bell
hanging on the locked door instead
the homeowner who is unaware of the
situation comes out and speaks loudly
causing the vests ripper apart
soon they find a storm drain to enter
the house
hugh crawls first through the storm
drain and then beckons them all when he
reaches the front of the house
the rest starts to crawl in when
suddenly a rattlesnake scares jude
making him screams hysterically the
attracted vests bite kelly's leg
hugh instantly distracts them by turning
on a wood chipper crushing the vests
that fly into it
finally the family peacefully enters the
house
later that night they treat kelly's
wound and ally tries to contact rob who
tells her that his parents are dead she
learns that religious cults have sprung
up after the disaster
she also tells rob to come here but then
the call is disconnected
the next morning kelly's wound is
getting worse and infected so hugh and
ally leave to find some antibiotics for
her
they arrive at the city with no one
around
they find a pharmacy store as a strange
man watching them from afar
inside the store hugh collects the
medical supplies and ally discovers the
disgusting vest bags growing inside
corpses abruptly the vesps enter the
store hearing to ally's surprise voice
hugh has an idea to distract the vesps
by activating a fire sprinkler and
manages to escape from the store with
ally as soon as they come out the
strange man approaches them and
introduces himself as a reverend he
tries to recruit them into his flock
named the hushed but hugh and ally
choose to leave him as the reverend
points out that he doesn't have a tongue
they return home with the antibiotics
and kelly recover swiftly allah learns
from the cnn news that vest cannot
survive in the cold place in the
northern parts they are calling the
place as the gray and there is no
electricity making people their cut off
from the world as their electronic
devices run out of batteries by morning
the reverend finds the family's hideout
and shows up with his followers he
requests you once again to join their
flock but hugh refuses and asks them to
leave
then the tongueless reverend writes the
girl as fertile referring to ally
enraged hugh brings out his gun forcing
the cultist to leave
in the evening rob let's ally knows that
he heads north to the refuge but the
internet disconnects after that thunder
rumbles as the whole family fall asleep
hugh and kelly are suddenly awakened by
a creaking sound from outside of their
house they find a shocked little girl at
the door after letting her in they
discover that the little girl has no
tongue and she is a member of the
tongueless cult
surprisingly they find a little girl
hiding several phones inside her clothes
and it turns out that some phones are
already placed around the house by the
cult the phones start ringing
simultaneously attracting the vesps to
attack their house
they are able to throw the phones into
the water stopping them from ringing
nevertheless the cult members manage to
break into the house and abduct ally
while everyone else is busy taking care
of the vesps
lynn who sees ally being abducted
follows them and tries to rescue ally
she restrains allies captors at the
expense of herself screaming and
attracting the vests to her in the
captors while ally escapes
unfortunately one of the cult members
takes ally as a hostage with a knife on
her throat they eventually fight back
and kill most of the cult including the
reverend who is severely beaten by hugh
a few weeks later the family travels
north across america and finally arrives
at the refuge
ally charges her tablet on an abandoned
jeep and receives a message from rob
telling her he's already there
lastly she reunites with him and they
start hunting the vesps with arrows
adapting to the new world
she wonders whether the vests will adapt
to the cold and whether humans will
adapt to a soundless lifestyle like she
did when she lost her hearing
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching